do you get the impression that the
appreciate that damages are already
being done to the banking sector you're
having to send you don't have set aside
funds for relocation potential
relocation you're making sure you've got
plenty of liquidity at the moment do
they recognize the fact that you know
banks are already beginning to suffer I
hope so because we keep telling them and
I think we the financial sector has been
telling them very very firmly now some
of this of course is inevitable I'm
afraid that if we go in for breaks it we
will find that jobs will leave the city
and that there will be a rebalancing of
financial activity within Europe the
city has been astonishingly dominant in
European financial markets in recent
years so some of it just to be clear
about that we will lose jobs in the city
as a result of brexit we will lose jobs
at RBS as a result of brexit some in our
case it'll be relatively small because
we are not a very large player in
European financial markets we have some
lending there which will carry on and we
have some financial markets activity
trading foreign exchange and things and
we're going to have to set up a
subsidiary in Amsterdam unless an
unusual what's a good assessment of the
damage to the cities or home I think
it's going to be quite considerable over
time because up to now people have
centered their European activities and
we're talking particularly about the
American banks the Japanese banks even
the Chinese banks and they have chosen
to put the enormous lion's share of
their activity in Europe based in London
and they're now rebalancing that's going
to happen whatever the outcome of the
presentations are so the game is can we
provide an outcome which minimizes that
cost it'll not remove it it'll
definitely be a cost and the question is
can we negotiate enough market access so
that that cost is at the margin you know
is a few thousand people not tens of
thousand could that cost be catastrophic
particularly if as seems increasingly
likely we have an ordeal brexit that
would be bad news because I think then
some quite large moves of people would
take place and you can already see some
signs of the impact you know London
property prices are starting to fall
compared to the rest of the country and
that's particularly so it's many would
say about time well it yeah does that I
you know one has to say
you're asking me about the financial
sector I'm giving you the answer some
people would say well hey these guys
deserved it and you know maybe we've had
finance has been to dominance in the
economy and those are some reasonable
arguments there but if you ask me will
this affect the city my answer is yes